so obviously you started doing fortnite
and that's where things kind of went
great that was the big yes so how did
you go from I assume when you started
fortnite it was already out obviously
and it kind of already had its own scene
how did you kind of see it and be like I
think I can do this differently and then
how did that translate to you becoming
the number one yeah so I mean I think
when it came out I had a million Subs so
I definitely wasn't like stuff yeah I
was doing like 150k yeah like a video
something
um I started when it first came out so
before anyone was really making videos
on it I was like I was there I wasn't
the first but I was like I was within
the first week or two of them I was sort
of at least playing it but then I was
having big issues with my eyes which I
still do to this day but um so I like
still kind of gaming for a little bit I
don't know um so I left it for like
three or four months and then I started
seeing everyone going skits on and I'm
like yeah
[__] them I wanna like what the hell is
[__]
um they're getting like six mil views of
video daily on this like this game's
crazy and like I loved playing it but it
was just like genuinely I couldn't look
at computer screens I was in heaps of
pain uh oh sure so I just said [__] it
[__] my pain I'm just gonna do it oh my
God it's just like burning you're like
all right guys
I sum it up by calling it like eye ligma
but I have like three like conditions
which are very good
but basically it means my eyes are
always red uh I'm in massive amounts of
pain when I look at a computer screen
and uh there's no moisture in Mars
um so it was just I picked the worst
profession in the world too yeah yeah
right look at a [__] screen but I was
like damn it was do or die I'm like
that's that's the most Aussie solution
I've ever heard in my life just like
[__] it mate yeah generally I was like
look how big this is I genuinely love
playing the game I love when I can make
videos on it I just want to do it I'm
just going to have to toughen the [__]
up and do it
um I don't know I don't know any other
person would have been like maybe I
should just do other content yeah yeah
yeah oh I try to do like uh Vlogs for a
little bit again
um I just struggled so much with like
organizing [__] to do everything about
coastal town like what the hell am I
going to do every day yeah like it was
like Logan Paul was popping off and I'm
like yeah how do they come up with [__]
to do everything yeah producers
producers yeah doing that on Bloody
Central Coast saying given it's a lot
harder when you're not near much yeah so
I mean I think it was kind of similar to
the sports videos where everyone was
like people were definitely doing
challenges they were doing meme things
they were having fun
but I was just so [__] at the game and I
still am but I just think I probably had
a slightly different
way of seeing things like it goes back
to that like even if I other people
doing challenges I just didn't a little
differently yeah slight slightly
differently I had done so many different
games of some stuff you did oh God
so the first one that was like the big
viral one was the first ever Fortnight
event I tried to stop it
I know it sounds simple now because so
many people other people did it yeah
like later on yeah
but everyone else went they just watched
the first Fortnight event right one of
my bless I think was toasted had the
idea of all sitting in Discord it's like
what if we stop it
I was like that sounds like a [__]
mad idea
we practice it every so we tried we
didn't succeed what was the strategy uh
so we just built a box around the rocket
ship I don't know if you ever played
fortnite or saw that event or whatever
it was but it was like a massive that
was Peak fortnite that was like ninja
playing with Drake era
um it was a rocket ship just going in
the sky so we're like let's build around
it so how did this event work like
there's a rocket oh so just in the game
at random one point it was like they
added this rocket ship to the game and
then like a few weeks later
they just took off right and it was like
it was like a countdown it was like the
first ever like worldwide in-game event
that everyone was participating in the
same so everyone shared the same space
or like so everyone if you loaded into a
game was seeing the thing the exact same
time but everyone's in different games
oh but it was just happening at the same
so you do different things where you'd
like have the time exactly when you
joined the lobby some people like the
game's ending as it was happening some
people got eliminated had to spectate it
happening
um but yeah we loaded up like practicing
we practiced a couple times watch Bill
like how quickly we could build it
um and then we built around it and it
just took off straight through it but it
was bang a thumbnail and people just
love the energy of like sitting there
just doing some dumb [__] like everyone
else just wanted to watch it yeah the
only one that did anything different for
that event would you say that's kind of
like your content brand just taking a
game and just being like let's just do
some [__] dumb [__] we've got it when
you're not good at him you gotta like
you know do weird [__]
um like I my favorite fortnite videos
the one where I won without moving
um and that's just the same energy it's
like everyone tries to get like 30 bombs
get 30 kills a month
but it's because I stream snapped my
friend who was in the same office
without him knowing and he was like a
psychopath at the game
um and I still got like one in a million
all the perfect circles all that right
but I was sitting in a tree I landed
straight in the tree sat there all game
um just got all the perfect circles like
one in the million he just deleted the
whole Lobby had no idea I was in the
game yeah looking for the last player
he's like where is this dude it's me I'm
in the tree so then I ran into his
office kicked him out of the game and I
got the victory right now so that was
like you know I tried for a week to get
it
um like just without stream sniping yeah
but I was like [__] I want to finish
this video I have to figure out how can
you actually do this and think outside
the box all right and actually I'd spent
like three months prior to that trying
to win completely AFK I had someone
literally I paid someone to just film
the screen as they just load into the
game and just don't touch anything just
to see if you can win completely AFK so
it was kind of like an evolving idea it
wasn't possible like it technically is
like was there anything we've got a
couple top threes and stuff AFK but the
circles would never go to where the AFK
players would drop right right so it's
just you'd have to be so obscenely lucky
the odds just weren't in your favor
we've played like 2 000 games or
something oh my God at one point we're
running like three accounts
but yeah no it was just like
you know I'm [__] so I can't do what
some of these other people are doing
what's organic to me that makes sense
yeah I mean you're using that to your
strength right and I feel that's like
something that it seems like something
that anyone can do but just like it's
it's it's the difference between being
like Oh yeah I could do some dumb stuff
because I don't have the skills to
actually like play the game normally and
then there's a difference of actually
committing to doing it right and I think
that's like the massive gonna sit there
for a week filming something you know
that's another thing everyone else not
everyone else like that's like a very
general statement but maybe like some of
the people that I knew where I was
watching or something like everyone was
so obsessed with like the daily fortnite
upload yeah and I I was forbid I would
try and stick to it but I was definitely
like if this video needs an extra couple
days I'm gonna give it to it yeah yeah
for sure yeah
um well I've heard uh that a meme now is
uh a meme that's crept up is uh your
upload schedule oh yeah no it's dog [__]
yeah what's uh is that to do with your
eye
in some ways because I added the
like I got help on like a couple videos
maybe like 10 or 15 right videos
throughout the years but otherwise I
edited every single video I ever
uploaded what wait do you still do that
uh if it's on my main Channel mostly
like I get some it was like nowadays if
it's on the main Channel someone will
like
do one of the run-throughs I'll add some
like extra things here but I'm still
doing the rough cut organizing I'm still
doing the Final Cuts and sometimes I'm
still doing the whole thing well that's
definitely not helping your Island um no
right so like God I think you're you're
this big and you still like edit your
own videos yeah I know like I'm still
I'm trying I'm like I'm trying people
I'm trying to get out of this yeah it is
like a mental ill I don't know it's a
bad thing you should never do it it's an
amazingly important early on to
definitely do everything yourself oh
yeah yeah you need to learn the skills
you need to know how to edit so when
you're talking to someone who edits who
doesn't like an idea yeah yeah you know
what they're going through to make
something happen so you're not giving
unreasonable demands or something like
that I think it's very important is it
just like the is it the anxiety of
handing off something that you made to
someone else or sometimes because I
think that's like a big issue with like
that was an issue with me when I first
got my editor where it's like I was
editing my own stuff for the first like
four or five years of my career and then
when I finally got to that point where
I'm like [__] I don't have the time to
like make these
yeah and also like I'm just not very
good at editing in general so it's like
and I don't have the time to like
improve on it so I always had that
anxiety of like well what if I give it
to someone and it's not exactly to the
vision that I wanted to or like how do I
keep I don't want to be that annoying
dude to just like constantly tell my
editor like fix this fix this fix this
when I could just do it myself right
like did you have that anxiety yeah I
feel like I definitely struggle because
I just
like no matter what and like I don't
want to say everyone sucks not everyone
sucks but definitely people have
different styles they have different
approaches yeah and I think I suck at
the fact that I am not very good at like
giving notes and stuff I'm like that
kind of person like oh [__] I was doing
myself like they'll send me back like a
test center like oh [__] I'll just
finish it yeah I was like because I'm
like oh I don't want to sit here I get
frustrated right
um like I said it's me being broken in
the brain I'm a very cooked individual
did hormone thumbnails did all that
that's just I thought I was like another
sound because thumbnails I would argue
is more important than the editing of
the video sometimes yeah yeah sometimes
because I mean yeah I I still have not
found someone that can edit thumbnails
exactly the way I want to uh yeah but
like in terms of doing your own editing
I'm still involved in my own kind of
like editing when it comes to my own
videos but in terms of like rough cut
that's that's a lot of work I I just do
like the finishing touches man yeah
especially for someone like you who's
like filming for like weeks yeah that's
why don't give it to them because I know
exactly from that like week of recording
what I want in it right so like what are
they going to go through like 25 hours
of raw footage or am I just gonna go
okay well 14 hours that was dog [__] I
know you can start stop recording but I
hate doing that right I I do like big
chunks and I go okay I know this part I
want in and I'll just do I'll do that
right yeah we uh we filmed we filmed a
video where we kind of like just drove
from like the most southern point of
Japan to like the most northern part in
Japan and we had like how many hours of
footage do we have for that one well it
was it was a 10-day road trip and there
was seven cameras on it yeah
yeah and uh we did not give our editor
any notes
that we just we just dumped like and how
did we go through that though so sorry
because he's a Batman like I don't see
that's where I'm like I struggle I'm not
like the best like when it comes to like
managing people or production processes
or whatever yeah yeah I'd have zero
goddamn clue yeah how many people are
you working with now how big is your
team oh I think there's
technically five of us five but that's
mostly just like oh you know
especially like oh I'm making a video on
Roblox like help me find like help me
test these Roblox games like more of
like
even if I come up with the initial idea
a lot of time it's helping me find the
stuff I need to make it around sometimes
a lot of videos just to have like that
annoying anyone could do this it just
takes 10 hours or five hours to do the
basic thing you're like I don't have
time
it's also good just bounce off people
get different perspectives especially
like yeah yeah I do Tick Tock videos or
something I'm not just pulling up a
YouTube compilation of tick tocks or
scrolling my own tick tocks it's like
I said that I sent those boys and I said
you've got a week find me the best hour
of tech talks and I'll watch the hour
and then we'll cut it down to 10 minutes
right that's like the selection process
for for that like that will literally
sit there for a week and grind out and
find like I think I said one time in the
start of one of them like I locked them
in a room and force them to watch Tick
Tock Twitter and I pretty much did
except they're in their own offices yeah
like
I just yeah I mean that's pots like
because I don't want to watch tick tocks
first yeah yeah so that part I I'm you
know I find it easy to get help because
you know it's it's
yeah it's like it's it's not the most
complicated thing but it's still like
they need to be funny they don't need to
understand what humor is yeah you still
do need to find the right people but
well that part's been all right yeah I
mean for a for a YouTuber your size five
people is actually like a really [__]
small team yeah from from like people
we've talked to at least I mean Mr Beast
as a 5 000 people yeah it's like a
village or something he's disgusting yes
I went yeah no in like a like
disgustingly good kind of way you know
what I mean yeah you've done a lot of
videos with them yeah I visited Preston
as well I don't know if you know Preston
but he's got like a team of like
40 or 50 or something now people
everywhere what's their YouTube handle
uh Preston I think he did a lot of like
Minecraft stuff and like uh gaming stuff
right
what the [__] are they doing I don't
know yeah I mean they they pump out
they're crushing so like they're doing
something yeah